11 years later and the original near has
now been remastered
for modern consoles in this video we
take a look at the boss fight in emile's
mansion
and see how the ps3 and ps4 versions
compare
it's worth noting that we captured the
near replicant ps4 version on
a ps5 although there is no specific ps5
version of this game available
now if you aren't already aware the
original version of near in america was
known in japan as
near gestalt and features daddy near
instead of the boy near so
obviously you're going to see some
pretty stark differences both in the
voice acting and the character model of
the protagonist
which is pretty fun to compare you're
also going to see a difference in
combat which has been revamped to play
more like near automata
if you enjoyed this video please give us
a like and sub and now
go enjoy some near this
is it we should find the cure somewhere
nearby
i do not like anything about this place
[Music]
[Music]
this book's kind of like you vice no
aren't we clever as if any mere tone
could compare to the wonderment that is
grimoire vice
that is eyes
petrification is appear some power
indeed
how many pages does this infernal book
ass
it's gotta be running low by now
this bastard ever gonna stop
there's no end to this pages of this
infernal book are
sharp as knives yes you never learned
that trick huh
[Music]
oh no i can't petrify it
and where have you
[Music]
where have been been getting stomped by
this thing
help i suppose strength is beyond
measure
what do we do i am an arcane text
not some manual of combat you are
supposed to deal with such matters
and where have you been
lost where have you been getting our
asses handed to us by a floating
kickstare is beyond measure
so what's the plan i am
thank you
vice this is it
research report on petrification well
well
[Music]
emil listen to me
[Music]
what is it kaine
[Music]
your eyes are not a sin don't ever be
ashamed of them
they're a vital part of you do you
[Music]
understand
[Music]
what's this a shade
[Music]
i thought i would only need it until i
had earned
my revenge once that happened
i figured it was all over
but there's a reason i'm alive that my
arm is alive
and there's a reason for your eyes
but listen
[Music]
no
i promise i'll never give up kaine but
you can't give up
[Music]
either